today marks five years since a white
supremacist murdered nine worshippers at
the Emanuel AME Church in Charleston
South Carolina they were shot and killed
during bible study at the historic
church called mother Emanuel because
it's known for its political activism
before the anniversary tens of thousands
of people hit the streets around the
country to protest racial injustice
Ethel
Leland's apparition mother Emanuel for
45 years was one of the nine who were
killed that day we spoke with her
daughter Sharon richer when we were at
the in South Carolina for the debate and
the church pastor the Reverend Eric
Manning who took over the pre from the
Peavey's pastor who died in the shooting
we asked them both how they're turning
the tragedy into a call for change after
the tragedy in Charleston there was no
really protesting or anything at that
time in the country and especially
Charleston we were so heartbroken too I
think get out and protest and riot now
what we see is the anger and the protest
from Charles school the anger from
Baltimore and Ferguson and all of these
things that's where this anger is in
people people are just tired not knowing
you leave your house and you might not
come back that you might find yourself
in a situation that goes wrong and then
you're dead so those protesters I
marched with them in my heart I march
with them yelling Emanuel nine but
country is in a place of reckoning and
we'd already know that this reckoning
has to come from the people that hold
the power the people who make policies
cultural changes there there's a lot and
that's where our country is
where we are today some would have said
that we should have been further along
with our race relations and we're not
just to be very candid it takes
leadership the highest level not to
necessarily get in the way but to lend
his or her voice to begin to usher in a
new year a new season within this
country we're all Americans black white
we're Agri garlis of the color of your
skin feel that this is home well the
Reverend Manning told us the parish will
march on Sunday to remember those who
lost their lives in the shooting five
years ago as well as George Floyd and
all the others who have died as a result
of police brutality Anthony I thought
that was going to be an interview that
I'd done with them I've talked to both
Sharon and the pastor and I thought they
were going to show that interview but
that was an interview that CBS did
yesterday that goes to show you never
assume bad things happen when you assume
but when you talk to them some people
will say it seems like yesterday I can't
believe it's five years but when you
talk to the people who were personally
affected by this they said it seems like
yesterday it never goes away and I
understand that I do too it was such a
chilling day I remember it so well Gail
and with you I can't believe it's been
five years but but it was just it was a
heartbreaking day and and I imagine for
them to see what's going on now is is in
many ways a continuation of that
heartbreak clear I think that's it wait
Tony just a sec before you go because
the thing that struck everybody about
that day the shooter that day had prayed
with them for over an hour before he
opened before he opened fire that's
something I can never ever forget
Tony sorry no no you're right it's a
haunting it's a haunting detail and it's
such a clear and hateful act of racism
and now the challenge today the
conversation today is is how do you
address not those clear acts but the
more subtle acts the more systemic and
an outcome-based acts where you know the
evidence is there all around us it's
just harder to look it in the face
because
it's not as clear-cut as a Dylan roof
case